paula möchte eigentlich im büro sein ein
hilfsprojekt unterstützen
stattdessen macht sie einen
bundesfreiwilligendienst wird
rettungssanitäterin ihre schwester anna
träumt seit ihrem achten lebensjahr
davon friseurin zu werden
das handwerk lernt sie aber bisher nur
an puppen stadt an menschen
martin macht bald abitur doch er muss
sich auf die herausforderung der korona
zeit neu einstellen
in der krise spürt er den zusammenhalt
in seiner familie wachsen und christina
fielen die echten menschen zum maßnehmen
die angehende schneiderin hält am traum
vom eigenen atelier fest
viele junge menschen und ihr weg ins
leben auf der fahrt dorthin hat corona
die bremse getreten
aber die reise ist nicht beendet nur die
rute verändert das erzählen uns baki
paula anna und christina sie starten
durch in dieser schwierigen zeit nur
anders
[Musik]
dem paula ich bin 19 jahre alt und
wollte jetzt eigentlich im beruf sein um
dort einen freiwilligendienst zu machen
aber das ist natürlich gerade leider
nicht möglich und stadt das mache ich
jetzt einen bundesfreiwilligendienst
hier in deutschland beim deutschen roten
kreuz im rettungsdienst
wenn ich diesen globus sehe dann ist da
auf jeden fall so ein gefühl der
sehnsucht fernweh und auch total viel
hoffnung ich hoffe so sehr dass ich die
möglichkeit bekomme werde so viel wie
möglich wie es geht davon zu sehen und
ja bis es soweit ist bis ich die
möglichkeit bekomme werde ich
hoffentlich das beste hier aus dem
machen was ich habe also vom
rettungssanitäter selber hat jetzt gar
kein bild
demnach hat sich der mann ließ blaulicht
und tatütata und ich konnte immer nur so
den krankenwagen zur mitarbeit erklärt
ist gibt den krankenwagen und den
rettungswagen und noch ganz viele andere
fahrzeuge
da würde ich im rettungswagen zu sitzen
man hört das martinshorn man sieht dass
da irgendwo das blaulicht reflektiert
und wie die anderen autos so zur seite
fahren stehen bleiben das war so würde
ich so ein krasses jetzt bin ich dabei
[Musik]
und so fest zu dass du ungefähr einer
hand luft heißt das kind ist trotzdem
fest aber es bekommt noch luft natürlich
sind solche geschichten selten aber
immer öfter dass junge leute sagen sie
wollen was mit ihrem leben anfangen sie
wollen auch was machen und wenn eine
sache nicht klappt ich habe noch einen
plan b in der hand es ist eine sehr
verantwortliche tätigkeit man arbeitet
mit menschen mit menschen in situationen
notsituation denen es schlecht geht und
man lernt hier eine ganz andere art von
verantwortung für andere zu übernehmen
und das prägt ein fürs ganze leben
es macht mir spaß aber es ist nicht das
was ich eigentlich möchte also ich
möchte ja auch in die welt ich möchte
eine andere kultur eine andere welt neue
menschen und auch mich selbst in dieser
hinsicht kennenlernen
also angst gar nicht im gegenteil ich
war schon mal ein jahr in irland so eine
art austauschbares und da macht es
erstmal für ein jahr weg wie man eltern
ja und peru ist für mich jetzt der
nächste schritt zu sagen ich möchte
nochmal einen ticken weiter ich möchte
noch mal eine andere kultur die nicht so
westlich ist wie jetzt irland und
dadurch auch noch mal mehr erreichen für
mich aber auch andere menschen
in diesen zeiten kann man einfach nicht
in die zukunft ich aber auch keine
glaskugel wir arbeiten daran versuchen
das möglich zu machen und bearbeiten
zusammen mit weltwärts und mit der
partnerorganisation trüben
aber versprechen kann ich das natürlich
wollte auch
so gesehen ist kroner definitiv eine
chance für mich also ich wollte jetzt
gerade eigentlich im ausland seien in
südamerika aber dadurch dass ich jetzt
eben hier bleiben muss hier in
deutschland und hier eine tätigkeit für
mich finden es musste habe ich
tatsächlich den einstieg in den
rettungsdienst war für mich entdeckt und
momentan könnte ich mir sogar vorstellen
die zehen zu studieren was für mich
vorher absolut so medizinstudenten sind
die da ganz oben
ich glaube man sollte das beste aus
allem machen weil man sonst frustriert
aber dann kommt man nicht weiter und ich
weiß nicht meine schwester das auch
schon mal gesagt wenn man einmal damit
anfängt wenig zu tun nicht zu machen
dann sind die kleinen dinge viel
anstrengender als wenn man sich alles
vornimmt und alles macht
ich heiße ware ich bin 18 jahre alt ich
besuche ein gymnasium in düsseldorf und
zurzeit wird statt 13 klasse das heißt
dieses jahr absolviere ich mein abitur
und ich hoffe dass ich dann in zukunft
in ruhe jura studieren kann
jetzt ist alles anders so was hatten wir
noch nie deswegen ist es auch so eine
schwere zeit geschafft ich kann man halt
so ganz normal absolvieren ohne dass
jetzt noch irgendeine würde dort zu
kommt man entwickelt ängste wie sich das
ist mit den abiturprüfungen aus finden
die prüfung überhaupt starten das sind
so fragen stellt man es schon das geht
dann halt eben auf die psyche man
vermisst natürlich seine freundin die
man täglich in der schule gesehen hat
von den lehrern etwas unterrichtet zu
bekommen wenn die vor einstehen dass wir
müssen wir auch um ehrlich zu sein weil
ich finde es ist was anderes wenn ein
lehrer jetzt wenn man ihm auf dem ipad
zieht und klar man lernt dort auch etwas
aber meiner meinung nach das ist
trotzdem was anderes wenn der lehrer vor
einem klassenraum steht und mir dann
etwas beibringen weil dalianis
persönlichkeit besser das schulsystem
ist für alle schülerinnen schüler von
anfang an ein fester ort der verlässlich
ist und selbst wenn der größte sturm
kommt die schule findet statt
und jetzt auf einmal war es so für diese
schülerinnen und schüler die schule sagt
ihr dürft nicht kommen
und das ist hier ist doch etwas diese
verlässlichkeit die immer dabei
die aufnahme ins wanken geraten ist und
das macht mit jedem schüler und jede
schülerin etwas
das familienleben bei mir ich habe jetzt
das glück mein bruder arbeitet das heißt
es tagsüber wirkt das heißt ich kann
tagsüber in ruhe lernen meine schwester
sucht sich jetzt zum glück nur eigene
wohnung das heißt während sie dort dann
weg ist kann ich auch wiederum alleine
lernen also es gibt tage da lernt man
dann schon mal fünf bis sechs stunden an
anderen tagen hat man vielleicht mal nur
ein oder zwei stunden
manchmal hätte ich meinem bruder gerade
in mattsilber der dort gerade
schwierigkeiten hat es auch gerade in
der korona krise daher die lehrer nicht
so oft nachfragen kann dann fragte mich
lieber und da ich auch max leistungskurs
hatte war ich öfter für ihn dauern habe
ihm dabei geholfen
gerade bei den hausaufgaben jetzt auch
in familien dem hat sich schon was
gehört einfach zum gemeinsamen filmabend
ich koch zum beispiel gerne mal mit
meiner mutter sachen das sind sachen die
man vorher vielleicht nicht so oft getan
hat das hat so viel verändert
ich bin meiner familie auf jeden fall
gestoppt da näher gekommen das kann man
auf jeden fall sagen
das abitur ist einer der wichtigen
sachen für mein leben weil ich möchte
studieren und das ist halt nur kurze
fragen dieses jetzt alle meine familie
stellt er hilft ihr schirm und ds auch
sehr fleißig also ehrlich gesagt der
wird schon irgendwie sein weg kennen bin
ich denke mal vergessen kann man das
alles nicht merkt dass er allein schon
wenn ich meinen freunden hallo sagen
möchte wenn man dann nicht weil ich
jetzt die hand geben solche die hand
vielleicht doch nicht geben weil ich
habe angst davor dass meine eltern dann
corona bekommen würden wenn ich das
jetzt mit nach hause schleppen hoffe
einfach dass alles bald ein ende hat
dass wir ganz normal wieder zur schule
gehen können dass ich mein hobby zu
ganzen abzuwählen kann dass ich ein ganz
normales leben führen kann einfach raus
aus der ganzen wohnung sagen wir das
wünsche ich mir
ich heiße christina schlaining bin 23
jahre alt und auszubildende zur
maßschneiderin im dritten lehrjahr also
eigentlich wollte ich nach meiner
ausbildung direkt durchstarten aber es
gibt einfach ganz viel was mir da so ein
bisschen die luft raus nimmt für dieses
jahr für meine ausbildung hat sich
einiges verändert an proben können nicht
stattfinden das heißt aufträge sind
eigentlich so gut wie unmöglich wenn man
die maße nicht vorher schon gegeben hat
oder in bestehende kunden noch mal für
die was anfertigt das war eigentlich
gang und gäbe vor dem lockt das man hier
schneider kurse gegeben hat sachen
beigebracht hat und ja auch gelernt hat
ja es ist natürlich momentan ist es
schwierig weil das schneiderhandwerk und
schon sehr viel nähe bedarf dass man
etwas zeit und ich den auszubildenden
über die schulter schauen
es ist natürlich jetzt etwas schwieriger
alles zu zeigen
christina ist aber im dritten lehrjahr
und hat sehr tolle fertigkeiten und
schon die ihre kenntnisse sehr erweitert
und kann letztlich selbstständig
arbeiten
wenn es kein corona geben würde dann
würde meine ausbildung eigentlich
ziemlich voll sein der ganze tag ist
eigentlich voll gepackt man fängt gerade
an irgendwas eigenes anzufertigen und
dann kommt schon der schneider kurs und
dann ist der tag auch schon zu ende also
da verging jeder tag ganz schnell und
jetzt muss man eben kreativ sein und
sich andere sachen überlegen
die berufsschule würde normalerweise so
ablaufen dass ich jeden donnerstag zur
berufsschule nach düsseldorf fahren
würde von mülheim aus und eben den
präsenzunterricht habe
da fällt natürlich einiges weg und das
was online geht das haben wir online
aber das natürlich sehr eingeschränkt
[Musik]
ich wohne seit ungefähr einem jahr mit
meinem freund zusammen in einer kleinen
1,5 zimmer wohnung unsere beziehung die
läuft eigentlich durch die ganze corona
zeit sage ich mal also es hat ungefähr
kurz vorher angefangen und dann konnte
man nichts mehr machen
ich finde es trotzdem sehr gut dass wir
halt auch miteinander jeden tag zeit da
bringen können ohne dass irgend wie wir
uns in die haare kriegen wenn jetzt
nichts anderes was anderes möglich ist
dann sind wir halt hier eine wohnung
entweder kochen wir zusammen oder wir
spielen schönen spiel zusammen gucken
vielleicht eine serie oder trinken
vielleicht einfach so nachts und beiden
und quatschen heutigen 8 man sieht ganz
gut dass wir die ganze gründerzeit
eigentlich auch trotzdem mit schönen
erlebnissen festgehalten haben ich habe
immer polaroid bilder gemacht oder er
das als schöne erinnerung obwohl sagen
wir mal diese tristen zeit jetzt auch
immer noch andauert aber sieht man auch
ganz gut an unserer fotowand die
pandemie hat uns irgendwie enger
zusammengebracht
da wir halt uns fast jeden wird wirklich
fast jeden tag gesehen haben menschen
miteinander verbracht haben konnten wir
halt mehr reden mehr und es hat die
unsere verbindung halt noch stärker
gemacht finde ich
aktuell steht mein gesellenstück im
vordergrund ich habe gerade die abgaben
von meiner entwurfs mapper gehabt wo
alles feststehen muss als ob jetzt darf
sich nichts mehr ändern meinen
hosenanzug ist jetzt im entwurf
abgegeben worden und jetzt kann es daran
gehen alles zu üben
in der maßschneiderei ist das so dass
man wirklich einfach handwerkliches
machen muss rim ist auch wirklich inne
zu haben um den vorgang zu lernen zu
wissen was man machen muss und somit
muss ich den hosenanzug so oft es geht
nähen um wirklich auch die routine drin
zu haben und in der prüfung erfolgreich
abzuschneiden
meine sorge was die prüfung betrifft ist
das teilweise fiel der theorie
weggefallen ist was mir für den
theoretischen teil nicht nur den
praxisteil der prüfung fehlt ich freue
mich auf das ende diesen jahres das ja
was neues wieder ansteht und ein neuer
abschnitt meines leben zurückgeben kann
ich bin an
ich bin 17 ich lebe hier in düsseldorf
und ich hab jetzt im august 2020 meine
ausbildung als friseurin angefangen
[Musik]
ich wollte eigentlich immer schon
friseurin werden also sind mit acht
glaube ich habe ich das einfach
beschlossen also jedes kleine mädchen
hat er seinen traumberuf aufsetzt
prozessen ist oder was auch immer aber
bei mir was halbinsel
ich habe jetzt 2020 im märz man
abschluss gemacht
zum richtigen abschluss hat nur leider
nicht wirklich dementsprechend war das
alles nicht ganz so wie ich mir das
vorgestellt hatte der übergang von der
schule zum berufsleben und mitte august
habe ich dann die ausbildung angefangen
ich habe mich total gefreut aber ja es
war leider auch nicht ganz so wie
vorgestellt mit den masken
puppen sind geduldig beschweren sich
nicht und es ist tatsächlich auch echt
was ich finde was im lernprozess hat
echt gestört ist im alltag später machst
du ja typ beratungen an den kunden wie
das gesicht ist anders jede kopfform es
anders und das ist im prinzip das
gleiche wie sich die gleiche kopfform
und halt auch seine kreativität wird
nicht so angeregt frau bergmann meine
absolute lieblingsstadt sehr umgänglich
beschwert sich nie sehr geduldig
so ein auszubildender sich die ist aber
tatsächlich auch wie offen bilder wo
muss man sagen dass das wirklich selten
also wir haben uns entschieden nur noch
auszubilden wenn wir total davon
überzeugt sind dass es jemand wirklich
will und macht und diana ist wirklich
auch genauso rechte hand kurz runter
wir überbrücken die zeit mit online
seminaren diana hat online unterricht
tatsächlich zweimal einer woche so wie
sie das auch in die berufsschule gehen
würde und wir treffen uns immer
zwischendurch um einfach tatsächlich im
übungs kopf haare zu schneiden zu finden
zu glätten
ich finde gerade allen jugendlichen wird
wo der wurde ein jahr gestohlen ein jahr
voller erfahrungen die man hätte machen
können die glaube ich auch zum beispiel
in meinem alter sehr sehr wichtig sind
was mir am allermeisten fehlt ist dieses
am ende des tages ein ergebnis zu haben
ein etwas was man geschafft hat im
moment du kannst nichts tun und unsere
unproduktiver du bist und so
unmotivierter wirst und das ist dieser
teufelskreis wird immer träger immer
unmotiviert haben und das ist halt
gerade echt das habe ich auch so in
meinem eigenen freundeskreis 17 18 19
jährige dass das halt wirklich auch auf
lange dauer schon fast zu depression
einfach führt also was wir jetzt noch
mal deutlich klarer geworden ist während
der pandemie ist es so wichtig ist es zu
wissen oder wie schön auch niemanden zu
haben
wo man weiß der helftaer schlecht geht
ich glaube die familie gibt einen gerade
in dieser zeit trost weil sie da ist
wir haben es tatsächlich zu hause immer
ein bisschen geprägt aber ja gerade wenn
dann doch viele menschen die ihm nahe
stehen weg sind zum studieren oder sonst
was
und man weiß aber so die geschwister die
sind da und man trifft die nicht nur
weihnachten sondern man weiß die sind
wirklich immer geändert
ich freue mich unfassbar auf meine
kunden ich freue mich darauf wenn hier
wieder normaler betrieb ist dieses die
einfach dass jeder stuhl besetzt dass
das ist so ein getümmel um einen herum
ist
alle reden alle sind unbeschwert und ich
freue mich darauf wenn es irgendwann für
alle wieder bergauf geht
[Musik]